[Music]
Hello friends and members of the Sum TV
family. My name is Sierra Murray.
Welcomed to I'd like to know, our Bible
question and answer program here at
Secrets Unsealed and Sum TV. I'm in the
company of two distinguished travelers
on the road to glory. To my right,
Pastor Steven Boore, our founder and
president. Pastor, always good to be
with you. It's a pleasure to be on this
program and answer questions. And to my
left, Pastor David Salazar, our general
manager of our Latino channel. David,
always good to have you here also. Thank
you. It's an honor for me to be with
both of you gentlemen. Now, we've got
some good news coming up in just a
couple of days. The general conference
se session, the 62nd session of the
general conference will begin in St.
Louis, Missouri. And it is our plan,
gentlemen, to be there and to
participate in this wonderful business
session of the church. But the fun part
really happens in the exhibit halls
where we get to meet all the ministries
and all see all of the things that are
happening at the general conference and
around the world as men and women lift
up the name of Jesus. Here's what we
want you to do and how you can join in
on the fun. We will be taping several
episodes of this particular program. I'd
like to know in our booth, booth number
107 in the exhibit hall at the general
conference session. As you can see, we
read these questions from time to time
at the beginning of the program. We
would like you to come to the booth and
ask your question in person. We'll film
you. We'll put you on camera and we'll
answer your question during our I'd like
to know uh telecast. So, that's how you
can help us out. Come to the booth,
shake our hands, bless the flesh as it
is, meet us as we meet you and greet us
as we greet you, but also spend a little
time asking your Bible bas based
questions and uh we will answer them as
part of our special general conference
I'd like to know programs. Now, as a
little inducement, I'm told by the
production department, gentlemen, that
uh we're going to give you a special
gift when you come and ask your
question. We're not going to tell you
what it is, but it's it's special.
You're going to like it. and uh ask your
question, we'll give you the gift, we'll
answer the question, and we'll have a
great time together. So, make that
promise, make that pledge, join us.
General Conference this year, July 3
through 12 in St. Louis, Missouri. We'll
see you then. Now, um Pastor Salazar, if
you would pray, we'll ask Pastor Boore
to give us the reading of this very
first question. Sure. Let's pray. Our
gracious heavenly father, we come before
you today to ask you to guide us into
the knowledge of truth. We ask that you
will please uh open our minds, our lips
so that we may answer according to your
will and may we answer questions that
will bring those that are watching,
those that are hearing give them the
knowledge and the understanding of the
truth in as it is through your son Jesus
Christ. Please thank you for being with
us and may once again may your spirit
lead us. We pray this in Jesus name.
Amen. Amen. Amen. Amen. Pastor Bor, if
you take this first question from
Colleen.
Well, CA, I I must say that this is the
first time in my whole life that I've
encountered this question.
It's a very interesting question. Yeah.
Uh and
um I'll be interested to know what you
guys are going to say about it. Sure.
I hope this email, by the way, it's from
Colleen. Uh, she doesn't say from where,
but uh, I hope this email finds you
well. I want to know more about demons
because my daughter seems to have come
under the influence of someone on a
social media platform.
This
influencer has an album on the social
media platform where followers post
photos of clouds that look like
demons. I can't see the demons except to
say that the clouds look like faces of
angry people or evil people or something
in that line. Just like one may look at
the clouds and see a cloud that looks
like the shape of a dog or a tree or a
baby etc. I'm sure that we have all seen
that clouds can look like images of
familiar objects. But these people in
the social media group are saying that
they see actual demons in the clouds and
they think everyone who can't see them
are not true Christians because we are
blind. So my question is, do demons hang
out in the clouds and sky? Are some
clouds demons? Thank you kindly for your
ministry. God bless you all abundantly
and always. So that's the
question. What do we say to this uh dear
soul to Colleen?
I would say this. If demons were
spending their time hanging out in the
clouds, praise God. You know, if if
they're wasting their time in the
clouds, then good good for them. Stay
there. The trouble is demons don't spend
time in the clouds. They spend their
time pestering the saints of God. Um,
I'm going give you one, two, three, four
or more texts. I don't have time to read
them because it'll take too much. But if
you write these down, they will kind of
give you where the focus of demons are.
Matthew
12:43, Deuteronomy 32:17 and 18. I'm
going kind of fast. 1 Timothy 4:1
and2, James
2:19, Acts
[Music]
19-16, Ephesians
6:10-13, and Mark 1:23-27.
These let us know that demons are quite
occupied trying to keep you distracted,
discouraged, dissuaded from following
the Lord. The Lord never sleeps, never
slumbers. Sadly, demons never sleep,
never slumber. They are constantly at
their job, which is why we must be
constantly at our job following Jesus
Christ. This, I think, is a distraction
of the devil. and and the devil finds
many ways to to distract us and to get
our minds off of what we ought to be
doing. Uh looking for demons in the
clouds and these kind of things.
Um you need to worry about the demon
that's on your track trying to keep you
from serving the Lord Jesus Christ, not
the one floating around in the clouds.
And I'll I'll put a little pause there.
Let you guys pick it up. Thank you. Uh I
will just I could just add to the fact
that you know there is a verse in
Ephesians chapter 6 verse 12 that
perhaps is where some of these so-called
evidence may may be the reason why
they're saying that the apostle Paul
speaking of what we have to wrestle
against says the following for we do not
wrestle against flesh and blood but
against principalities against powers
against the rulers of the darkness of
this age against a spiritual host of
wickedness in the heavenly places. So
maybe I could see uh some you know
so-called uh Christian leader whatever
trying to pose and say there that's the
verse to say that in heavenly places in
the heavens there the angels are
dwelling but that's not what it's trying
to say at all. It's not limiting or
saying that the demons are in the
heavenly places otherwise they only will
tempt those that are in a plane. You
know it doesn't make sense. Uh it really
is speaking in regards to our like you
mentioned pastor the struggle that we
have against heavenly or divine origin
agencies good versus evil. That's what
it's really speaking of. And so that is
a legal battle. Now what is this
individual trying to do? Uh right now
there are so many and thousands of
images circling the internet that are AI
made. Some of them some of them are just
great people that can create the
illusion of things that are seen in
particular pictures or photos. So if
they could be doctorred they could be
made up these things or if they were to
be kind of real like like she said I can
see the clouds and I see some angry you
know faces that is nothing to do with
demons. I I think that this uh young
lady who's uh you know following whoever
she's following the influence that she's
receiving I think that she needs to go
to the word of God to understand what
the struggle really is and like you said
pastor to emphasize that we need to put
on the ar put on the armor of God and to
truly spend time in scripture knowing
the Lord so we are not deceived with
this so-called uh you know fest of
Christianity it's completely unbiblical
what is these guys are presenting to be
bottom line Jesus never said search the
clouds he said search the scriptures
exactly exactly you know what
particularly disturbs me about this
question is the part towards the end
where it says but these people in the
social media group are saying that they
can see actual demons in the clouds and
they think everyone who can't see them
are not true Christians because we are
blind
Why would you even be looking for demons
in the clouds? Precisely. You know, why
not follow the council of the Apostle
Paul? But we all with unveiled face
beholding as a mirror the glory of the
Lord are being transformed into the same
image from glory to glory just by as by
the spirit of the Lord. 2 Corinthians
3:18. Why would they even be looking for
demons in the clouds? Why not spend
their time beholding Jesus Christ as
savior and lord? How wonderful he is.
Amen. You know, don't get don't exalt
the devil by looking for the devil in
clouds. Yeah. And remember that only
one's going to come through the clouds
is Christ in his coming. So if they're
trying to even give the idea that in the
clouds demons are, they're actually
speaking against, you know, the coming
of Christ. So it it really goes against
what the Bible teaches and I hope that
Colleen can help her daughter really uh
emphasize the fact that she needs to
spend time in scripture and we are you
know this is where really we find the
truth not not in some you know picture
on image on the internet. You know this
this these little things that we have in
front of us here are wonderful wonderful
tools but they can distract and destroy.
Yeah, if you get unfettered access to
these things, you really got to be
concerned about what you consume, what
comes in through your eyes, what comes
in through your ears, because the devil
is one, a liar and a deceiver, and
that's what he's doing. So don't swallow
wholesale everything that you see on the
internet. So much of it is is are just
lies and tricks of the enemy to distract
and and discourage and destroy your
soul. The Bible says if there's virtue,
if there's praise, think on these
things, not all of this stuff that comes
through through the and that's good
counsel for the world. It is especially
good counsel for those who would be sons
and daughters of of the Lord. What would
be the purpose of searching for demons
in the clouds? I mean, what would the
ultimate purpose be? Uh it just doesn't
make sense at all. Yeah, it's not
biblical. I mean, Christ mentions so
many times in Matthew 24, beware of
false prophets and false teachers that
will rise up and deceive many. And we
have to be very careful that we don't
follow because they trying to make an
emphasis that looking on those demons is
what makes you know who's if you're a
Christian or not. That's make, you know,
again, why would your Christianity be
tested by your ability to see demons?
Yeah. Yeah. And especially in the
clouds. In the
cloud. And and we we're chuckling a
little bit, but we know this is very
serious because the devil will use any
trick. He will use anybody anytime,
anywhere, any place on any occasion to
try to discourage you and to move you
out of the arms of Jesus. You can't let
that happen. So, Colleen, we are praying
for you. We are going to pray for this
situation and and uh you need to sit and
have a a good talk with your daughter,
good spiritual talk, and let her know
that that the devil is not uh your
friend. He's trying to destroy you and
uh you've got to hold on to Jesus
Christ. Amen. All righty. Very good. We
move now to Guyana, South America. Uh
pastored many people from that country.
Uh this is William. Uh greetings pastors
from Guyana, South America. My question
is God told Jacob his name would be
would no his name would not no longer be
called Jacob but Israel. That's in
Genesis
32:28. But then in Genesis 46, God still
calls him Jacob. Please
explain. It's a good question and I
think that I like the fact that William
is um searches the scriptures. you I can
see that he's uh looks at the scriptures
and you you're right in the sense that
Genesis
32:28 as after he had the battle Jacob
with the angel with Jesus he receives
that blessing of having his name changed
and the Lord says your name will no
longer be called Jacob but Israel now in
verse two of chapter
46 it says there and I'm going to read
Genesis 46:2 then God spoke to Isra
Israel in the visions of the night and
said, "Jacob, Jacob." And he said, "Here
I am." Notice how the Bible in this
particular verse says, "God spoke to
Israel and said, Jacob, Jacob." Now, now
you may say, is the Lord like going back
and saying, "Oop, oops, I called you the
wrong name. Uh, you know, I shouldn't
call you Israel." It's interesting to
see that he in this verse, you have both
names. God called Jacob. I mean God
called spoke to Israel and said Jacob
Jacob meaning and I I believe this is
really the verse explains sort of what's
happening those both those two names are
interchangeable they are both part of
Jacob one shows I mean the name that he
had legally when she was or or the one
that was raised as he was growing up the
one that God established was the one of
his victory with Jesus but in ultimate
sense both names were used to him just
like today we have I have two names and
it's the same way with is with Jacob and
Israel they were both names given or
used by Jacob in his experience in his
life you know an evidence of this we
find for example in Isaiah 49 and verse
6 where those two names like you were
saying are used interchangeably the fact
is that he was still Jacob you know that
was his birth name right and so people
were going to know him as Jacob and even
God would call him Jacob but also
Israel. Uh in Isaiah 49:6 it's talking
about God's mission for Israel. And it
says indeed he says it is too small a
thing that you should be my servant to
raise up the tribes of Jacob and to
restore the preserved ones of Israel. So
in that one verse Israel and Jacob are
used interchangeably. M we shouldn't get
all hung up and and and think that uh
you know when God changed his name
nobody would ever call him Jacob ever
again. The fact is that they're that
they're interchangeable. Yeah. Another
interesting point is that when he called
him Jake I mean when the Lord called him
Israel.
He didn't want Jacob to be and and and
he says you're not your name should no
longer be Jacob. He's trying to
emphasize the fact that he's not only
going to be Jacob. That's where I was
heading. you know, that's not going to
be it. You're not going to be named
Jacob anymore, like which means a liar
or a suppler. You're going to have now
another name which Israel. And I think
it's also interesting that God uses both
names because to a certain degree it
shows in a practical way in in a type
what is the experience of his own
church. Many times people, you know, are
under the old nature, if you will, you
know, that are dece deceivers, liars,
you know, unfaithful to the Lord. But
the Lord wants to give each of his
children a name of victory. A and so it
sort of represents to a certain degree
the experience of every human being who
comes to Christ in need of a change, in
need of a savior, and with Christ they
can be victorious. So, it's it's almost
like a way to remind individuals the
need to have Jesus to come in their
lives to transform them and give them
the victory. I'm going to give what I
would call a halfbaked idea, but it's
something that occurs to me that I'm
going to check out more. I I what what
occurred to me in looking at the many
times that both names are used is that
when God wanted to emphasize the
corporate or covenant aspect of the
relationship, he used Israel. when God
wanted to emphasize the one-on-one rel
relationship with with this individual,
he used Jacob. And I'm gonna play with
that a little bit more. But it I I see a
pattern there. When when God was talking
about reminding of of his destiny, what
he was going to do, what it what was
going to lead to the the covenant
aspect, Israel, when hey man, I need to
talk to you, Jacob. You know, that that
kind of thing like like like uh you are
pastor Steven
Boore. I call you rabbi. You are both.
You are both because Rabbi Sim means
teacher which you are a great teacher
but you were born pastor Steven Bore. So
you say yes to both. Amen. I hope people
will not identify with the rabbis of the
times of Christ. I didn't call you
Galia.
But it just needs teaching. Galia was a
very wise teacher in Israel. It was the
exception to the rule.
Yeah. We praise praise the Lord for or I
didn't call you Caiaphas. That's the
word I wanted.
So, as you can see, we have fun on this
program because we love the Lord. We
love each other. So, um William,
hopefully this this answers your
question and uh uh we've had a little
fun with it and thank you for sending
sending it
in. All right, quickly we can try to get
in Nelson from Uganda. uh had the
privilege of preaching there uh and the
union office there Uganda uh in simple
terms how are we to understand that God
is spirit in this verse John 4:24 pastor
Salazar if you get that for me God is a
spirit and they that worship him must
worship him in spirit and in truth there
is a prevalent notion in Christianity
that understands spirit as some
intangible and immaterial being but I
understand that God sits on the throne
uh The acts of sit, the act of sitting
requires a physical body. Jesus sits at
the right hand of the father. Um, sister
white also asked Jesus also asked Jesus
in a vision if the father had a form
like himself and the response was yes.
All right, let's wrestle with this for
just a little bit. All right. I I think
that it'll be good to just read verses
23 and 24 so that we get back to, you
know, the bi Bible declination of what
Jesus is saying. And uh actually I will
actually read from verse 21. I think it
makes more sense. This is Jesus talking
to the woman in the well and he says to
her verse 21, John 4:21, "Woman, believe
me, the hour is coming when you will
neither on this mountain nor in
Jerusalem worship the father. You
worship what you do not know. We know
what we worship. For salvation is of the
Jews. Verse 23. But the hour is coming
and now is when the true worshippers
will worship the father in spirit and
truth. For the father is seeking such to
worship him. Verse 24, God is spirit and
those who worship him must worship in
spirit and truth. That's what the verses
are saying. So um Christ is establishing
a concept here in response or to the
question whether or not it was right to
worship in one mountain or the other.
Christ starts to answer and to open the
eyes to these women that God it's not is
even though he's specular about the
place and he actually me mentions them
you know Jerusalem was the place the Jew
salvation comes from the Jews. This is
where the Lord has established the hour
has come or is coming where God wants
not just the external not just the
fulfillment
of external duties or or or or habits
but also to understand that truth must
be uh spirit spirit and truth must be
given in in the ability of worship God.
So he is she he's explaining that God is
a spirit and like the angels like the
like the host in heaven we are to come
to the Lord understanding that he's holy
that he's just that we are to heap uh
attitude of worship to God and and of
reverence to God and of of of
fulfillment in in fulfilling his word in
what we are able to do. Um I don't know
if pastor B has something else to say.
The bottom line is that u it's not
saying that God is a ghost. Yeah, that's
the way that people understand it that
uh that God the father uh is kind of
like an ethereal ghostly
uh bodyless individual. But uh Ellen
White made it clear that uh you know in
a vision that he mentions that uh you
know God uh is actually on the throne in
heaven. God is not personally
everywhere. God is aware of of
everything that's going on everywhere.
He's omnisient. He doesn't have to be
present everywhere personally to know
what's going on in the entire universe.
Um you know if you took this to its
extreme God is
spirit and though and we must worship
him in spirit. If when it says God is
spirit it means that God is intangible
then we must worship him being
intangible as well because we're
supposed to worship him in spirit. Yes
as he is spirit. So it's just saying
that God is a spiritual being. Yes. Uh
you know a spiritual in the sense that
we understand the word. It doesn't mean
intangible, ghostly, bodyless. That's
not what it's talking about. Yeah. Well
said. Uh the text says God is spirit,
not a spirit, right? Capital S. And the
we worship in in small s spirit. So the
context is she's trying to get out from
under the heated questions. You worship
here, you worship here. And Christ is
trying to tell her that's not important.
God is spirit. Wherever you fall down
and call on the Lord, that's when you're
in the presence of God. Doesn't matter
if it's in Jerusalem or Samaria, that's
not important. God is spirit. And when
you come to him, you must do so in
spirit and in truth. And so, he's just
trying to he's trying to refocus her
because she's trying to get out from
under a whole lot of other things that
that Christ is kind of bringing into her
life that she doesn't really want to
want to deal with at that at that point
in time. And and having said that uh
Ellen White has told us that the nature
of the Holy Spirit is a mystery. Yes.
Right. You know we know the nature of
the father and the son through scripture
but the nature of the holy spirit is a
mystery. Uh the holy spirit is like
wind. You know it uh you can you can't
see the wind but you can see the impact
of the wind. And so the holy spirit you
know the holy spirit's a person. You
know that the holy spirit produces
fruit. You can see the fruit of the
spirit. You know that the holy spirit
gives gifts. You can see the gifts in
the church, but you really uh should not
try to define exactly what the spirit is
uh because the the spirit is in some way
even though he's a person distinct and
different from the father and the son.
Very true. There are some things that
that we cannot successfully wrestle with
just now. It's just a little beyond our
current understanding. We'll talk to the
Lord about it when we get to the
kingdom. Amen. All right. Again, our
time is slipped into eternity. Allow me
in closing again to wish you both grace
and peace through our Lord and Savior
Jesus Christ. We will see you again
soon. We wish you God's blessing.
Bye-bye and God bless.
[Music]